HBO just announced on Game of Thrones official
Twitter account that Game of Thrones prequel
series, House of the Dragon will begin filming
with the start of 2021.
Beside this announcement, they also teased
two dragon concept arts of the dragons
that are going to play a major role in this
prequel
and those dragons are Aegon II's Sunfyre and
Daemon's Caraxes.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens fought
Targaryens, bothers fought brothers, dragons
fought dragons. By the time it was over, thousands
were dead. The conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only House
Targaryen, but large parts of Westeros as
well. In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
The dragon that played a huge role in this
Targaryen civil war was Ceraxes,
one of the dragons HBO shared its concept
art.
Caraxes was the dragon ridden by Prince Daemon
Targaryen during the Dance of the Dragons.
A veteran of many battles, he was known as
the Blood Wyrm for his red scales.
Caraxes was one of the older and larger dragons
during the Dance of the Dragons.
Daemon Targaryen rode Caraxes in his frequent
campaigns in the Stepstones.
As a result Caraxes was not only one of the
larger dragons during the Dance,
but the most battle-hardened and experienced
in war.
Indeed, only Vhagar had ever been ridden in
major wars before, during Aegon's Conquest,
but while formidable, Vhagar had not been
used in combat in the years leading up to
the Dance,
the way that Caraxes was.
Opposing armies were known to often simply
flee or surrender when Caraxes approached.
When Rhaenyra captured King's Landing in a
surprise attack, Daemon rode Caraxes in the
assault
while Rhaenyra rode Syrax. Later in the war,
Aegon II's younger brother Aemond Targaryen
resorted to a one-man war riding Vhagar, burning
out much of the Riverlands.
Daemon hunted him for a long time on Caraxes,
aided by other dragonriders and their dragons,
but eventually he returned alone to Harrenhal
waiting as a challenge for Aemond to arrive.
Caraxes was formidable, but Vhagar was twice
his size, nearly as large as Balerion had
been during the War of Conquest. Facing him
alone was the only way for Daemon to draw
Vhagar out,
however, as Aemond had avoided ambushes by
multiple other dragons. Aemond arrived,
exchanged his final challenges to Daemon,
then both took to the air on their dragons.
The resulting Battle Above the Gods Eye was
one of the most epic dragon-versus-dragon
fights of the entire civil war, as two of
the greatest living dragons fought in the
air.
Their shrieks shattered every remaining window
in the castle and could be heard for miles
around.
Their fire-breath filled the sky so that fishermen
in the lake thought that the whole sky was
aflame.
In the end, Caraxes dove down from the sun
on Aemond's blind side (due to his missing
eye).
Caraxes slammed into Vhagar and they both
continued to fight in free fall.
Vhagar tore out Caraxes's belly, and used
her massive jaws to rip one of his wing-arms
completely off - but Caraxes sank his teeth
into Vhagar's throat and maintained a death
grip.
As the two dragons grappled, Daemon rose from
his saddle and made stunning mid-air leap
from his dragon to Aemond on Vhagar's back.
Wielding the Valyrian steel sword Dark Sister
(which had once been carried by Vhagar's previous
rider, Visenya Targaryen, Daemon thrust his
blade through Aemond's empty eye socket - the
force of his impact as he landed driving the
sword through the back of Aemond's head. Both
dragons plummeted into Gods Eye below. Both
dragons and both dragonriders died.
Daemon's corpse was never found, but Aemond's
was found years later with Dark Sister still
thrust through its skull. The battle was a
heavy blow for both Rhaenyra's and Aegon II's
factions:
each side lost one of their greatest champions,
as well as each side's strongest dragon.
The other dragon concept art HBO shared is
for Sunfyre. Sunfyre, known as Sunfyre the
Golden,
was the mount of Aegon II Targaryen during
the Dance of the Dragons. According to some
sources, Sunfyre was the most beautiful dragon
ever seen upon the earth.
Sunfyre had gleaming gold scales and his flames
were golden as well.
Sunfyre was a relatively young dragon. He
was not considered one of the "large" dragons
like Caraxes. At the same time he was very
much at the upper end of the "medium" dragons,
very strong and formidable in combat. As the
conflict between Aegon and Rhaenyra intensified
into full scale war, Aegon II grew increasingly
impatient with his grandfather Otto Hightower's
diplomatic maneuverings, and wanted to launch
an immediate attack on Rhaenyra's followers
on the mainland. With Lord Commander Criston
Cole, he launched a campaign into the east
of the Crownlands.
This culminated in the siege of Rook's Rest,
when Rhaenys Targaryen arrived riding the
large older dragon Meleys to attempt to lift
the siege of the castle. This was all a trap,
however,
as the Greens had kept two of their own dragons
hidden and in reserve
so they could take Meleys in an uneven fight.
Aegon II appeared riding the younger, but
strong Sunfyre, and his younger brother Aemond
Targaryen also attacked riding massive Vhagar,
the last of the first generation Targaryen
dragons. Rhaenys could not prevail against
such odds, yet she did not flee,
but flew head-on to meet her attackers. Meleys
was still so large and powerful that she put
up a brutal fight. When the dust settled Meleys
was dead and Vhagar was relatively unharmed,
but Sunfyre had been nearly killed and permanently
maimed.
Meleys managed to nearly rip one of his wing-arms
completely from his body,
and as for Aegon II, he was left horrifically
burned and with multiple broken bones.
Aegon II was taken back to King's Landing,
but he was left sedated with milk of the poppy
for months, and command fell to his younger
brother Aemond. Sunfyre survived the battle,
but the world's most beautiful living dragon
was left crippled and heavily scarred, just
like its rider, Aegon.
Yet even after Rhaenyra captured King's Landing,
her forces could not find Sunfyre, nor Aegon.
Aegon II escaped King's Landing to hide out
as a disguised commoner
in a fishing village on Dragonstone island
- the last place that Rhaenyra would search.
Sunfyre also subsequently flew to Dragonstone
after he gained enough strength to fly.
When Sunfyre arrived he fought and killed
a remaining riderless dragon, Grey Ghost –
although he took yet more wounds in the process.
When Aegon finally rode Sunfyre again
he was attacked by Daemon's young daughter
Baela riding the dragon Moondancer –
an even younger dragon barely large enough
to carry the 13 year old girl.
Moondancer was quick, however, while Sunfyre
was still half-crippled and slowed by his
injuries.
Therefore they were evenly matched and their
duel was ferocious. It culminated when Sunfyre
tackled Moondancer in mid-air and drove her
into the ground below:
his larger size meant that he survived the
fall while she was killed.
Nonetheless Sunfyre was mortally injured by
this fight, and would never fly again.
When Rhaenyra was forced to flee King's Landing
due to a city-wide riot,
she returned to Dragonstone only to be surprised
and confronted by her half-brother.
Aegon II then had Rhaenyra fed to his dragon
Sunfyre
while forcing her last remaining son to watch
(Aegon III Targaryen).
The dragon roasted her alive and devoured
her in six bites. Six weeks after this, Sunfyre
died.
Despite being one of the younger dragons in
the Dance,
Sunfyre actually shared the highest dragon
versus dragon kill count with the massive
Vhagar herself:
two individual kills and one assisted.
Both Sunfyre and Vhagar died as a result of
their third dragon fights.
For that matter, they were the only two dragons
in the Dance who ever lived through a dragon
versus dragon fight and lived (most dragons
in the war were actually killed by human armies,
or died in mutual kills in their first battle
against another dragon).
So many dragons had died in the war that the
Targaryens could not maintain a stable breeding
population, and few survivors became inbred
and sickly.
Lots of dragons, a lot of epic dragon battles,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel series, House of the Dragons brings
in 2022 on HBO.
Let me know your thoughts about everything:
the prequel, its characters,
the mighty dragons and their epic battles
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and hope to
see you in the next one.
Peace!